next generation sequencing for ngs
also called high throughput sequencing
is a popular method to generate
many types of onyx data and it's a very
exciting trend that started about 2010
when people started realizing that you
can analyze
the complexity of subcellular
bio bio biological processes
using one type of a machine which is
this next generation sequencer
so first of all ohm
means collection and a comprehensive
collection of something
so we can think about phenomics how
we can analyze a collection
of phenotypes for example when we look
at this image of
the cell culture there's quite a number
of things that we can
categorize it's cell size morphology
maybe the tissue that it came from maybe
different kinds of
variation that we can see here with the
size of the nuclei
so together all of these parameters
could be referred to as phenomics
then we obviously have what's called
genomics and so
the genomic revolution that we are
experiencing today
largely because of the low sequencing
costs
uh refers to genomic variation genomic
variation could be
single nucleotide variation we can have
synonymous and non-synonymous mutations
that affect or don't affect the coding
sequences
it could be variation in the genomic
regulatory sequences
so there's quite a number of genomic
type of
data that we could analyze
epigenomics which comes from the field
of epigenetics where we're interested
in the regulation of transcription
based on non-genomic variation so
micrornas not
long non-coding rnas different types of
methods for pull-down techniques like
immuno
precipitation when we analyze chip seek
data for example or whole genome by
sultan sequencing and then finally
transcriptomics and so the objective of
transcriptomics
is to look at this continuum and
close the circle right so as a proxy for
protein expression we can look at mrna
expression
looking at cdna right so which is a
copy that we've identified in the dna
region
that actually is encoding the translated
mrna sequence
and so that's what we're talking about
in this program how do we analyze
mrna expression using this cdna proxy
and so to understand this a little bit
better let's kind of talk about
the process so as you remember we are
looking we're trying to analyze
the expressed proteins and so the
express
proteins come from translated
messenger rna so in the process of
transcription
the mrna is produced
and then with the ribosome we could
capture
those pieces of translated mrnas and we
could
sequence them to see what is going on so
what could be going on
what could be going on is we could
identify the specific
proteins that represent the activity of
a cell
or a property of a cell so a property of
a cell could refer to
membranes pro membrane proteins those
proteins that
are maybe helping us determine
what kind of a cell it is what tissue it
comes from or what is its function
it could also show us what kind of
signaling processes happen in the cell
or it could reveal subcellular processes
that are happening
at a given moment in time so it could
really tell us what is the cell doing
what is what is its function what is it
uh maybe trying to do right and so as a
result of that
we could understand the condition in
a very precise molecular fashion
many methods of rna sequencing come from
the microarray data
analysis technique so before this
next generation sequencing became a
thing became
kind of like an easy and accessible data
type there was
first generation sequencing and first
generation sequencing really refers to
to sequencing using sanger sequencing
where we have to annotate the whole
genome
and select specific regions to sequence
and it's a fairly complicated
labor-intensive and expensive process
and so before sequencing was applied to
measure
mrna expression people relied on other
techniques like
northern blot or then came the
microarrays and so the microarrays were
really invented
in the 2000s and
we see how in the 2000s
those microarrays became very very
popular and the reason why they became
popular as you can see right here
it is based on this hybridization
technology and produces
continuous data continuous data means
that the visibility and the
luminance of these dots
really represents a continuum from 0 to
255 right so you can really measure
abundance of mrna present in each cell
and so this is like a flow cell
inside each cell you have some specific
transcripts that are complementary to
the transcripts that are expected just
like you see right here so in each one
of these dots you have these
uh little pieces of mrna
and then when mrna from your sample gets
put on this microarray it lights up and
so
as a result you have this continuous
data now
what led to the emergence of next
generation sequencing two things
the first one is that we now understand
that mrna transcribed
in the cell could be detected
by looking at the genomic sequence
where it came from and so because we can
identify exons
we know that those exons are transcribed
into mrna we can then also
start looking at real mrna variation and
there's more variation to it than just
abundance which is what we can capture
in the microarrays
so besides abundance we can also look
at what's called alternative splicing
and i'll talk in a little bit about the
process of next generation sequencing
and you will see
what are some of the important
challenges that come as a result of this
wider dynamic range so the wider dynamic
range here refers to
ability to capture abundance as well as
alternative splicing events and
characterize this
across multiple samples that represent
conditions so really it becomes
a statistical problem to identify first
where those reads are mapped to
from mapping to identify how they are
distributed
per sample because we were talking about
bulk rna so we're
actually talking about sampling multiple
cells and then to infer
from there which is what you see right
here how that helps us
differentiate or discriminate between
different cell types so here you can see
that
actually genes might have a lot of
overlap because we are using here some
kind of approximation
but when we are talking about this more
detailed view of isoform and alternative
splicing
or exon specific expression we actually
do
have a lot of times a clear separation
between conditions
so in this program or what omics logic
is intended to provide you with
is an understanding of how these
techniques actually fit in to
conceptualize a process of biomedical
discovery and so biomedical discovery
really is independent of the data type
because it typically refers to this
integration or association between
the onyx data type which we will focus
on and
the ability to describe the phenotype or
characterize that condition using
clinical data
chemo informatics data and other types
of
data sets that are used for diagnostic
and therapeutic purposes
and so that is why this program is
called rna-seq
for biomedical discovery so before we go
on
i wanted to make sure that this portion
was clear so if you have any questions
please let me know you can put them in
the chat box and we will be happy to
answer them
i really want to make sure that we are
moving along at a pace that everybody is
comfortable with
and so if you need a little bit more
time or you feel like something was not
clearly explained please do let me know
in the chat box
now i think to really appreciate how
these methods could be used in real life
or in the real world
we need to rely on projects that are
sourced from
important data sets that are available
in the public domain so
why is it good as a resource
um okay and i mean actually here
is asking could you elaborate what you
mean by abundance
okay so i will talk about that in just a
second
but here you can see some examples of
biomedical
projects so why we use this project
driven method
to explain some of these uh technical
essentially methods of analysis the
reason is because
there is a true integration between
computational side and biological side
you really have to be able to appreciate
the biological problem at hand
before you start choosing the methods of
analysis and applying them
to a data set that you have chosen and
so for example
one of the things that we often include
in this kind of a discussion
is the problem of tumor and its micro
environment
so everybody has heard of cancer and the
way that the tumor grows in a particular
tissue
and more and more of the applications
of this kind of analysis and biomedical
applications
have to do with the tumor micro
environment why
the tumor micro environment represents a
collection of
a number of different types of cells
some of them immune cells some of them
are
from the surrounding tissue that could
characterize
in a much better way what is this
tumor's property so for example it could
help us
understand the mixture of different
types of cells
selection of immune cells and
characterization of their properties
but also then to understand how the
tumor interacts with the tissue that it
is surrounded by
so to talk about this challenge
we'll talk about pdx models which are
patient-derived xenograft models models
that are mice they're animals but they
have
a human tumor that is in grafted in them
and because of that
using the simple mapping technique we
could differentiate between
the micro environment which is
essentially mouse tissue
and the tumor which is human tissue
okay let me pause you real quick and
answer these questions so that we can
move on
what do i mean by mrna abundance
imagine a gene that gene is being
expressed and this actually relates to
this
image right here so here i have what's
called a heat map and this heat map
i am trying to represent different genes
so here i have a list of genes and here
i have
different categories or classes of
samples
so when i have a gene for example erbb2
that is highly expressed and i know that
it is typically associated with a
particular type of
of samples then i can look for whether
that
is up regulated or down regulated so if
it is expressed a lot
what could that tell me that could tell
me that a lot of the
cells in a given tissue have that kind
of an expression
and when i look at how i can target
a particular pathway and that pathway
let's say is a signaling pathway if i
target erbb2 or her2 for example
i know that i have a targeted therapy
that could affect
that whole pathway and that pathway
essentially prevents
this hyper growth that we observe in in
tumors so that that is a good example of
what i mean by abundance i need to
detect
how many reeds or the abundance of reeds
that map
onto that genomic sequence of that
particular gene
to understand whether that is present
and being expressed
and whether this target is a viable
target in the context of that
targeted therapy that's just an example
okay tripty was asking can i elaborate
the word chemo informatics so chemo
informatics
refers to information about the chemical
properties and structures in a given
sample so if we talk about a protein
or a ligand a chemical ligand
we can characterize those properties we
can look at atom properties we can look
at
how they interact with each other or how
they interact with other types of atoms
for example
how they interact with other charged
molecules water
etc so that refers to the word
chemoinformatics when we look at
chemical properties across different
types of
chemical structures and ligands
um okay so can microarray
differentiate between isotypes
i am not 100 sure what you mean by
isotypes
maybe you mean isoforms so isoforms
are transcripts genes is just the
recorded gene sequence in the dna but
when that gets produced when that gets
transcribed there's what's called
alternative splicing so
multiple exons are spliced together
sometimes in different order or in
different combinations
and that is what we call an isoform
essentially it's an isoform of a protein
right but we're using
mrna as a proxy for the protein and so
can microarray differentiate between
them yes only if it was designed to
so you will a lot of times see in the
microarray data
instead of how many of you by the way
know how many genes are in the human
genome
maybe vj you know how many genes are in
the human genome
just throw out a number i mean you can't
go wrong you're not graded on this
all right there you go 23 000 right so
somewhere
based on different groups it's somewhere
between 20 000
and 30 000 it's about 22 500 right so
those are 23 000 is a good estimate so
when you look at microarray data instead
of 23
000 you actually see that it's like 60
000. so why is that
because you can represent each gene by
multiple
transcripts and there are some
transcripts that are known transcripts
and we'll actually talk about this in
a few minutes when we do a practical
hands-on assignment
so you will see that a lot of times
the microarray design
includes known variation in order for
a person who is analyzing that data to
capture all the variation that is
present but
since we don't know all of the possible
variations we are likely to miss some of
them because if we want to include
all of the possible variations it's just
going to become
too much of a you know too many
things to measure so that's really uh
the answer to your question
uh final question what do i mean by
samples
so when i say samples i actually mean a
biological sample when i take
a tissue or a cell line and i extract
rna from that single
sample that becomes represented using
digital data and that digital data
is associated with that sample where it
came from okay so that's the biological
sample and actually that's a good
point to also expand upon when we talk
about
the need for normalization and
incorporating that understanding in
our downstream analysis okay and
tejus thank you for your other questions
let me continue i will make another
pause in just a few minutes
we'll talk about other questions as well
so we talked about diagnostics and
cancer biology right this is an example
uh disease classification and patient
stratification what does that mean so
when you deal with a patient's
population we are saying that okay we
could categorize patients
using their gender for example their sex
male and female we can talk about their
age
their young age 20s and 30s old age
50s 60s 70s we can talk about
comorbidities or clinical classification
where we say okay this person also has
diabetes and heart disease
this person is obese this person is
healthy and running right so we can use
different categories to classify
patients now
this makes sense because we tend to
think of people
as objects that have these clinical
characteristics that's the clinical
approach right you kind of look at the
whole person you say this person has
diabetes
but when it comes to selecting treatment
for example
for cancer you don't essentially know
what is the impact of these
comorbidities
or these clinical parameters on the
actual tissue or
cell types that you are treating and so
it makes sense to think about them
as molecular combinations of tissues or
cells
that could be characterized using gene
expression
data so you could take samples from
these patients for example biopsy from
their tumor
sequence them to understand variation at
the gene expression level
and based on that make decisions that
have to do with
signaling pathways or molecular
characteristics of
advanced or less advanced uh tissues
and tumors and so that's an important
part because
ultimately using molecular
characterization of
patients or disease stratification you
can
develop gene sets that are predictive of
what will happen
in a person based on treatment based on
disease progression
based on rate of recurrence etc so we
will talk about that
as well and then finally as we all know
taking a bulk or an ac sample is like
measuring the temperature in a whole
hospital right
you will have people that are in the
morgue right that are already dead
and you will have people that have acute
infection and very high fever
and so if you average between the two
your average temperature might be normal
but in reality that does not represent
the different patients that
are in your hospital and so the same
thing with tissues and cells
you can take a whole tissue or a whole
sample biological sample
but when you don't consider the
individual cells and cell types
you lose a lot of the variability that
can have a direct relevance to the type
of biomedical problem
that you are trying to solve and so
we'll talk about
single cell and tissue decomposition or
in other words how can we characterize
the tissue based on the
true variability that we observe in that
biological sample
so ultimately this whole program is
designed to provide you with an
overview of tools and resources for
transcriptomic data analysis
it will provide you with an experience
and we'll do that a little bit of that
today
of how to process next generation
sequencing data using
what's called bioinformatics pipelines
and we'll use our
t-bioinfo server to do that then we will
do analysis normalization
and visualization of gene and isoform
expression we'll provide you with some
automated tools we'll talk a little bit
about how to deal with this data in
excel
but we'll also show you some tools in r
and python that typically
work as a package that you can learn how
to use
or modify so that you gain
some insight into your data we'll also
talk about
big data mining machine learning and
predictive analysis so what we talked
about now
how to use classification clustering how
to do predictive analysis on different
types of complex data sets
where you have hundreds of samples maybe
across many different types of
variations and so how do you go beyond
statistical analysis to do that
we'll talk about analysis of single cell
or an ac data how we can look for
tissue specific expression or cell
specific expression which again
has a very important significance for
immunotherapy
and all kinds of understanding of immune
responses to
different types of conditions and we'll
talk about
different types of projects so once you
understand how these tools are used
how do you apply them in the context of
your own personal project right and that
project
will be sourced from the public domain
so we'll introduce you
to a number of different data sets that
you can find
on repositories like the national center
for biotechnology
information ncbi geo gene expression
omnibus
how you can go to places like tcga the
gene
uh the cancer genome uh
project and others so we will talk about
a lot of different repositories and how
to actually
find a data set and start asking a
research question
about that data set so the way that this
program will work so valid already
mentioned this but i want to emphasize
that we will have these regular sessions
well
where we interact face to face like
today
and before i talk about the other
aspects could i ask everyone
to just for a brief moment turn on your
camera
so we can see who joined today as you
can see my face i would love to know
who else is here so uh all right great
great to see you thank you very much so
again
the purpose of these interactive
sessions
is to be able to also meet each other
and understand where everyone is coming
from
and what do you actually expect to gain
out of this program and so
great thank you everyone for turning on
your cameras we'll just give it
a moment for the others to do that as
well
um so this program isn't just about me
and about the participants we have here
it's also about you
and so we would love to get to know you
in the process of this
learning experience we would love to
understand uh
what you are currently working on uh if
you're a researcher
a student uh perhaps you are trying to
apply
some of these methods to a data set that
you are interested in
um and so you know that is another big
part of this
program is to really hear from you and
understand
i'm sorry i understand where this is
coming from
okay so i will save this screenshot it's
wonderful to see all of you
and uh if you want to turn your cameras
off now that is fine
and hopefully in this program we will be
able to
[Music]
get to know you a little bit better so
let me describe now
how this program will actually work
so this is the link that we have
all of the program sessions organized in
you can actually go to learn
let me actually paste this link in the
chat box
okay so on this link
you will find this program and by the
way if you're already registered
on the learn portal you can just click
on programs
and you will see the programs
right here these are the programs that
we have but this is the program
that we're going to be uh looking at
today so
once you're logged in and you're a
member of the program
you will see the overview as well as
courses you can book a meeting with
um our team so you can actually schedule
a one-on-one mentor session if you have
the subscription
for that uh there is a section here for
our slack channel and so those of you
that already registered
you can go to ask question and you will
be able to join our slack channel so
i'll just show you how that works
so here i have the people
joining the slack channel and i can
actually post a question so for example
i can write question how
do i find a data set
on rna seq okay
so now you will find this appear right
here
so this allows us to communicate back
and forth
and that's the objective of this program
we don't just give you some resources
and tools to use but we also
can have a discussion so if i now
reply to this and
[Music]
sorry if i reply to this
there you go and you can go
okay something like this so that will
now
appear here as well right so that way we
can have a discussion
about these topics if you don't
understand something if you have
questions about something you
are free to post that right here and
importantly in between the sessions that
we have
in this interactive way there are some
additional
resources that you have the freedom to
go on your own pace
so that's an important part of it we
understand that many people have
a very different pace of learning you
can learn
by just attending sessions and asking
questions and learning about the
hands-on exercises that we do together
or you can learn more technical things
by completing this coursework
and so we have some introductory
introductory courses
we have some comprehensive training on
transcriptomics
and then you will see that we have also
some project examples that you can apply
the methods that you learn to a
particular data set this is a data set
on the tcga
the cancer genome atlas we also have
some courses that you can practice
coding for example in python and r
and and we'll add some more projects
here as we go along the way
so let's take a look at some of the
topics that we will cover
but before we do that um let me know if
anyone has any questions about
this uh page again some of you might be
seeing
a different view and that is because
you're not registered for the program so
just to kind of
illustrate what that looks like if i go
to the
program page and i see this
when i'm not logged in so i'm not a part
of this program
you can see that just the information
about this
program is available so you can see the
sessions
you can see the schedule of these
sessions you can see some of the things
that are being
offered and some of these testimonials
and if you want to complete your
registration
you can complete your registration using
one of these options
beginner which does not give you access
to
one-on-one mentorship intermediate
that provides you with one-on-one mentor
support and advanced
that also gives you extra time to work
on a research project that gives you
access to some of the big data analysis
tools that we will be using
throughout this program so if you any
you have any questions think about those
questions
and let us know in chat or
follow up by email later on
okay so mohit here is mentioning
that it would be great if the syntax is
explained in the coding exercises
so i will get to that in just a few
moments i'll give you an example
uh sorry i'll give you an example of uh
some
of the exercises where the coding syntax
is explained but
we will talk about that and thank you
for that comment
all right so let's go back to rnac
one example that i want to show you is
an example from a real data set
that we will be analyzing using the big
data analysis
platform so that you can appreciate the
launch
of rna-seq analysis so how
how's the data mapped how is it then
analyzed for variation
using comparisons between different
conditions
so if you could please again once you're
registered on the learn
platform so once you're registered here
the same password
will be used for this big data analysis
platform
so i'm going to give you just a couple
of minutes
if you could follow to this link
again you have to understand the
you you have to use uh the same
password and please let me know once
you're here
by putting in something in the chat box
so that i know that you're here and i'll
give you just a couple of minutes so
in the meantime i'll explain what this
is
so our company is essentially
a tech transfer company so we work with
a bioinformatics research center at the
university of haiti in israel
that center is focused on computational
tool development so they're really
focused on making bioinformatics
accessible to anyone with or without
a background in bioinformatics and with
or without
engineering and programming training so
it is for biologists
and for clinicians okay and i'm going to
continue talking about the platform
until i start seeing that some of you
are already here and have logged in so
please once you are here and logged in
put in something that's in the chat so i
know how many people are
following along so one of the uh
projects that they have been working on
for the past several years
is this big data analysis and
integration
platform and the idea behind this
platform is to offer tools that are easy
to use
across several different types of omics
data
like next generation sequencing mass
spectroscopy
structural biology as well as tools for
data integration and modeling
in this program we're not going to be
able to cover all of these tools but
we're going to
rely on a number of these tools to help
us appreciate
the process of analysis of rna-seq data
some of the introductory data mining
tools
and then data visualization and
biological interpretation
all right great so i see that one two
three four
five people are here let's give it just
a few more moments
until everybody else is here now you
need to be here and you need to be
logged
in how do you know that you're logged in
you know that you're logged in
if you hover over this right here you
will see your email
right here
okay so one two three four five six all
right two more
minutes and then we will go on so the
way that we
use this in the context of our training
is first of all we're going to show you
some demos
in these demos you understand the logic
how do the
different steps connect to make a
pipeline to
make a working analysis workflow and
then once you are able to replicate
those demos and you understand all the
inputs outputs
and the steps in between you will then
be able to
analyze your own data so then we'll
transition
into a more hands-on practical analysis
of your own data or data found on the
public domain
so to get a sense of what that looks
like let's go right here you can see
transcriptomics and the first section
in transcriptomics is basic processing
of transcriptomic data
so let's go into this first demo rna-seq
cell line project
okay how many of you already have some
experience
in rna-seq data processing and analysis
is there anyone here that has already
bioinformatics experience
okay avinash is saying that he doesn't
have that experience yet
okay so
he's saying that yes he does that's
great
so if you don't have any background
in rna-seq data analysis this will be
a little bit new and you might want to
repeat this again you're on your own
for those of you that already have that
kind of an experience
i want to kind of also explain why this
is a useful interface for you to
appreciate the different methods that
have developed over time
and how they compare to each other so
that you can make
comparative analysis of these processing
steps
first of all let's click on the first
button called start
here we have the three main steps that
this pipeline offers us to do
pre-processing so when we generate those
digital reads
and those reads are in abundance we know
that they
have been prepared using library
preparation techniques
in other words there's adapters short
sequences that are used when those reads
are generated
so that's problem number one problem
number two
the amount of reads has been amplified
using pcr and so because of that
bridge amplification there is
a difference in abundance between
different types of sequences because we
know that pcr
is just biased some sequences are
typically more amplified than others
just because of the type of sequences
that they are and so that represents
some technical variation that is not
wanted right it is going to skew our
results
and it's going it might have an impact
on our biological
interpretation now this is especially
important when you deal with
genomic data because you might be
finding
variants because of those adapters and
not because of the true variants found
in genomic data but in transcriptomic
data this is important because
some of the highly expressed genes
tend to be affected a lot more by these
pcr amplification techniques and so it's
important to eliminate that technical
variation
the second part is mapping what is the
challenge
with mapping does anyone can anyone
explain to me
maybe just in two seconds two sentences
in chat
why are there so many tools for mapping
of these reads onto the reference genome
i mean what's the problem
you take a read and you place it
somewhere on the genome
why is this such a big area of
bioinformatics tools and how come we
have so many of them out there
okay i'll give you another two minutes
to
think about it why do we have so many
tools
let me just close this and i'll show you
what i mean by many tools
so here we have a mapping section all of
this section
refers to mapping we have here star
bsql b bow tie bwa top hat hiset
okay so zara is saying i think not full
coverage of gene's
sequencing so i'm not sure exactly what
you mean zara but
okay favor is also saying because there
are many transcripts and we do
we need to find the right positions of
the transcripts before making meaning
use of the gene info okay so
yes the number of genes the number of
possible positions so
to appreciate why we need so many
okay we need to actually appreciate how
this data
gets generated right so let's briefly
take a look this is the session where we
talked about
how data is generated in next generation
sequencing
so let's just talk a little bit about
what that is
right so here we have um
sorry here we have
here we have a complete pipeline and
when you start you essentially load the
data
into your pipeline that data could be of
many different formats
and many different types of sequencing
so you have different
protocols you have different types of
sequencing like parent
and single end you also have different
types of
read links and you have
different amount of reads for the whole
sample
so you can have millions of reads but
you can have 10 million 5 million 3
million right so different coverage
so parent and single end different
methods of data preparation using
different library techniques
library preparation techniques different
sequencers that produce different
lengths
and ultimately you have also different
genomes now how long
is the human genome can somebody tell me
how many nucleotides are in the human
genome
okay perfect 3 billion 3.2 yep
about 3.2 billion nucleotides how long
is a read
does anyone know how long is the typical
read sequence
what's the length
okay 151 3. the truth is it's
between 30 nucleotides and about 350.
there are some long read sequencers that
now sequence up to maybe
thousands of base pairs but typically
we're going to be dealing with
anywhere between 50 and 150. so let's
take a look this is a pipeline for
a complete rna-seq analysis but let's
build a pipeline to just
understand the read mapping part of it
so we'll click on start
we'll go to bow tie 2g which is
one of those mapping techniques onto the
human genome
which as we know is 3.2 billion
base pairs so we take a short read 50
base pairs
and we have to find a place on a 3.2
billion
length okay so we'll click on ok
and then we'll click on visualization so
we'll see how do those reads
actually map onto this reference genome
i'll click on end okay you can follow
along but you don't have to i'm just
going to show you
the output of this pipeline again we'll
take a look at what is
actually going on so these are
individual reads and as you can see they
have been mapped onto this reference
genome
and if i click on this read okay first
of all you can see that they are
red and blue okay how long
is this sequence
how long is the sequence of this one
read
150 okay thank you favor
right you can see right here sequence
length 150. so 150 letters
have to be mapped onto this long long
reference sequence
not only that you can see that some of
them are read
forward and some of them are blue
backwards so they
are complementary sequences they go into
directions
that gives us higher confidence in how
the mapping is done
but it represents quite a significant
technological challenge and so
when you think about the applications of
genomics or rnac
data analysis tools
those are two very important trends the
development of sequencing
technologies which led to longer reads
more accurate reads and cheaper reads
and at the same time these computational
tools that
started to develop analysis methods for
quick mapping okay so so
let's go back okay let's go back
to our pipeline and see
what are some of the other methods that
we have here right so we have both type
2g this is just
mapping onto the reference genome
and we know that there's 3.2 billion
positions on that genome
we could in an alternative way map
onto the transcriptome what is the
transcriptome
out of the 3.2 billion only one percent
are actual coding sequences so what is
one percent
from 3.2 billion mathematicians out
there
and i see here somebody is asking for
the link so we're actually just
using this pipeline right here okay who
can calculate one percent of 3.2 billion
okay um sorry i i don't think that
yeah people outside of india actually
know what
means so neither do i i think it's
something like um
a hundred thousand but i'm not sure
okay is saying 32 million
so what is a billion
okay i won't torture you but you can
appreciate now the difference between
millions of positions and billion
billions right 3.2 billion so there is
a difference of there is a huge
difference
in how many positions we have to survey
to
find the best mapping place for a short
read
and so instead of using bow tie to g
let's start
another pipeline to see what that would
look like
we can actually map our data onto the
transcriptome
okay but before we do that let's
pre-process our data
we'll eliminate the adapters
clean up pcr clean and we'll learn in
our next session about
this pcr bridge amplification
then we will add the reeds map them
onto the transcriptome or all of the
expressed genes
all of the exons essentially that are
present in transcripts
and then we have to create a table
right a data frame we need to create a
table of expression
and so when we create that table of
expression we're also thinking about
how that table represents the
statistical complexity of
the data set that we have here what is
the complexity the complexity is that
genes are of different lengths
and there's different number of reads
for each sample
and so when we look at preparing a table
that we want to use for downstream
analysis
there are some normalization techniques
that we have to learn about
to normalize for read length or sorry
for gene links
and for the total abundance of reads
available
so that's why we use different methods
like fpkm and cpm
and now when we complete our pipeline we
will see here
a number of outputs like the expression
of genes
exons and isoforms
okay for tripty how do you access this
screen
you go to server.tbioinfo right so again
this is the link
i'm just gonna put it here
so if you go to this link you have to
sign in
and use the same account information
like you created on learn
okay okay so this gives you a snapshot
of why we use this tool
this tool is easy to combine
different methods different steps
together in a workflow like a pipeline
it's reproducible i can remember what i
did
it is color coded so you know that all
the blue is
pre-processing all the red is mapping
all the green
is quantification and
you can also perform both data
processing so like we did
now or you can use also comparative
analysis or use of statistical tests
to identify genes that are
differentially expressed
okay so this was just a brief example
does anyone have any questions about
this example that we did
okay if you do have questions put them
in the chat box we'll run some pipelines
we'll understand
the logic behind analysis we'll be able
to see some
outputs that are both visual and just as
data sets so this is a volcano plot
we'll talk about what does it mean and
how to use it
and we'll talk about biological
interpretation how do we actually
understand the meaning the biological
meaning of thousands of genes that we
potentially have in a given sample or in
a given differentially expressed
pipeline
and then we'll talk about how do we
account for the variation in our source
samples in the biological samples
and what can we do to explore and
normalize this data
as well as explore this data to inform a
data-driven research
question we have a number of courses
that
combine statistical analysis methods
with an understanding of complex gene
expression patterns
normalization techniques that involve
log scale transformation
and we'll also talk about data mining
and classification well we'll talk about
different methods
of big data analysis that are commonly
used to cluster
and classify such data so then we will
talk about
how this applies to specific biological
examples like the ones i mentioned
in the beginning in cancer we have
different subtypes of cancer
how do we understand their differences
and how can we ask
questions about those differences and
then we'll introduce you to some coding
exercises
where we will explain how to load this
data visualize this data
and also how to perform some similar
analysis steps using
coding so that coding will be done using
our code comics logic playground so
let's
take an example of one of those
exercises
okay tripty after you log in
maybe the best thing would be to
actually view this
uh recording that we will share with you
and try to do that there okay so let's
take a look
at an example of a coding exercise
that we will do in this course okay so
what i'll do
here this is on the course page so if
you're already here
i'll just give you one example of how we
will
load and visualize this data using r
so here's an example let's go to data
visualization
okay so when you deal with data
different types of data go with
different methods of analysis so you can
have
uh maybe information about your input
data about the different samples that
you have that typically will be
categorical data categorical data means
i have
five samples that are er positive five
samples that are
triple negative five samples that are
her2 positive something like this right
so
it's categories there's no continuum
between them
there could be continuous data and
continuous data
means that i have gene expression
anywhere between zero
all the way up until hundreds of
thousands and i have all the possible
ranges in between there's no major
breaks there's not just like
a lot of fives and a lot of tens and a
lot of 100s right
it's just continuously a continuous
scale
and so for the different types of data
you can use different visualization
techniques
but before you actually visualize the
data you need to learn how to
load it and how to understand what's in
it because your data frame that you load
can have
numerical data in a matrix it can have
some headers
that explain what each sample name is it
could have some row names that
you know specify gene names so we have
to be able to
prepare our data before we actually
visualize it
and so what this uh these steps do
is they actually provide you with an
explanation and then offer you some
practicing
steps that you can do on your own so
you can actually practice this right in
your browser
let me share the link right here
yes vijay we will definitely provide you
with some
data sets and those will be introduced
in the context of that project
okay so here we are loading some data
you can see that i'm creating a data
frame so first of all it's just an
object right
r is an object-oriented language so we
create an object
and we add here a data table so this
data table
you can look at what does this table
actually look like so let's
copy this link and we will put it
right here this is what the data looks
like
there are some names on top this is the
header and there's some genes right here
for simplicity they're called gene one
two three etc and in between
we have some numbers so we can go in
here and we can load this table and
we're saying here
skip one okay so we are going to be
using
this code is an r okay so you can see
here
that we are loading this data we are
then creating a data frame
we're removing some of the non numeric
data
creating a matrix okay and we can then
check
the mean so we have the mean
for our data so what's the average or
what's the mean
for our expression values okay and so
this is a very simple step
you can do this exercise and this
exercise is for a given data set now
i can change this data set right i can
take another data set
and check the same right here now how to
visualize this data again you can just
simply
run this code okay and you can see that
there are several types of plots that
you can create
what is this called this is called a box
plot
or a box and whisker plot because it
represents the interquartile range
maximum and minimum as well as outliers
that are present in each sample
so here you can see sample names
here you can see a complex visualization
called the heat map
where you also cluster your genes and
your samples together to represent the
variation by groups
or you can look at the distribution of
data
and you can see that there's an maybe
something
that is not normal right about this data
for example here you have
a lot more low expressed genes than what
you would expect from a normal
distribution
so now you can modify this for example
if i
change this to purple
okay you can see that now this is purple
this is actually
going to work and i can modify this and
the
objective of the future steps and
exercises that we will do is to take
some
practical coding exercises like these
going from very simple to more and more
advanced
up until you're able to write your own
code
so as you go through these exercises you
will go from very simple just press a
button and change a little thing
to eventually completing whole sections
of code
so that you understand how to write code
on your own
there are also going to be instructions
on how to download and install
r and python on your own computer on
your own machine
because ultimately this online
environment is going to give you some
limited
expertise but you have to set up your
own environment where you have your own
files
you can install your own libraries you
can explore different tools that are out
there
in the public domain okay let me finish
with one last thing
um i see that uh
vijay was asking how do i find some
data where do i find some data that i
can practice with
okay so harsh why are we converting the
data frame
into a matrix there are different
methods
some methods only work with numeric data
which is a matrix
and some methods know how to handle
headers in a combined data frame
and so based on the different methods
that we use we either have to
prepare a matrix first or we can use the
full data frame but sometimes we need to
transform it into a different format so
we'll talk about these formats in our
sessions
if you copy the file location details
and paste but the feedback says the file
doesn't exist
check the link if the link opens and it
does exist then it should work
yes so mean actually we have a platform
so we have a server right so we're using
a server the server runs
a an r environment that is handled by
our server so that way
we don't need to go through the steps of
everybody installing
our making sure you have all of the
different packages
and dependencies and things like that so
this is just a simple way for us to
all do the same steps together
all right so where do you find these
data sets and where do we
find the projects that you're going to
be doing in this program
you find these projects for example on a
place called
ncbi the national center for
biotechnology information
so i'll just paste the link right here
okay can anyone here provide me with
a you know a topic a biomedical let's
think about some biomedical topics
yes i will show you how to download some
data sets
from here but somebody give me a topic
what are you interested in
some kind of a let's say liver cancer
diabetes okay starts growth two perfect
so let's look for source code two
okay star scope two obviously there's a
lot of different
types of information about source code
too so when you scroll down right here
you see a lot of different types of data
now for our purposes for transcriptomic
data analysis there are going to be two
repositories that are going to be most
interesting the first one is geo
which stands for gene expression omnibus
okay so these are typically
already tables of gene expression that
you can just download and analyze
or snra which is sequence read
archetypes
and so remember the pipeline that we
built to actually process
the individual reads and map them onto
the reference genome to create a table
of expression
that's what we would use here now you
can see that there's a lot more
sra than there are geo
and the reason is because s arrays
combine individual
samples each sra is an individual sample
and here in the geodata sets they're
grouped together
but also not all of the sra data sets
that are available
on here are already processed and
available for you to download
so here we can take a look at some of
the existing data sets that we can just
download
and for example you can see here over 2
900
samples right 1702 samples
so there's a lot of samples already here
784
right 493 407
363. sorry a lot of samples
let's find something with less samples
okay these look like individual
samples
okay and so here you can also customize
you can say i want to look at
high throughput sequencing
and change it to that
also we can customize it by um
there's just huge samples right sample
sets
but you can see that you can easily
download them and obviously you can uh
you know explore them on your computer
so just to give you an example
96 samples okay 88 samples right here
you can just download this data
again you can see that it comes in many
different formats
for example raw counts which you can use
for differential gene expression
normalize counts okay and then
log transform account so let's just
download draw accounts and i'll show you
what that table looks like
okay so here you have a data set let's
open it real quick in excel
we'll look at what it contains
again i'll share this link with all of
you remember to download it for yourself
all right so we can see here the id
so there are some lung heart and other
tissues
and you can see the name for example
let's take a look at
i il-33 which is interleukin-33
a gene responsible for inflammation
and we can look at okay what are
uh what is its expression across the
different
cell types that you have right so here
you have some variation it is highly
expressed in just a few samples
and typically it's low expressed so this
kind of a cytokine is typically
expressed
when the cell gets infected and actually
dies from infection so
now you can appreciate how this type of
information
could be useful to differentiate between
different samples that we have
in this dataset
all right so thank you for listening to
my part of the presentation
i will now pass this on to dr mohit
mazumder which will be
one of the mentors who will help you
develop
projects and guide you through the steps
of analyzing your data
and also we'll be able to show you about
how the training registration process
will work and what are some of the
upcoming opportunities
for us to learn about different types of
omics data in the context of this
program
over to you